foreign
in november 2020 we released assassin's
creed valhalla
to our delight it was the biggest launch
for any assassin's creed game today
and we have you to thank for that
becoming avor a viking leader going on a
quest to fight for a new home
is an adventure that resonated closely
with many of you
i certainly had fun exploring england
with avor
and stumbling across unique world events
that left me with memorable side stories
we're amazed to see how you dedicated
yourselves to the viking lifestyle
you've led more than 300 million raids
in total
and built more than 100 million
buildings in your settlements
congrats avor still has a long journey
ahead
and we've been continuing to offer free
updates for all players to enjoy
post launch these updates include time
limited festivals
new quests and even whole new game modes
such as the river rates update
and the mastery challenge
we add in community requested tweaks and
features too
for instance we'll be adding one-handed
swords in the coming weeks
the team is also working hard at
tackling issues and improving the game
experience for everyone
we've been tracking various known issues
on our forums and also shared our
complex
bug fixing process in a recent dev blog
we love seeing your continual feedback
and we thank you for your patience and
support for the game
on top of regular free updates we're
also building on avoir's story and the
world of assassin's creed valhalla
through game expansions wrath of the
druids released a few weeks ago
allowing players to explore ireland and
battle a mysterious cult
the children of danu
in our second upcoming expansion you'll
get to relive the siege of paris
this is the most ambitious battle in
viking history
taking place in war-torn frankia you'll
have to do everything in your power to
uncover enemy secrets
and form strategic alliances in order to
safeguard
your clan's future players may be
excited to learn that black box
infiltration missions
are returning this means you're given a
goal for a mission
but how you'll achieve it is up to you
expect new abilities
weapons gear and of course
new enemies watch out for the siege of
paris coming this summer
assassin's creed has long focused on the
exploration of history
and we are happy to announce that the
new discovery tour will be released
this fall it will be free to all who own
assassin's creed valhalla
explore the world and take a deeper dive
into the history of the viking age
the team has crafted a new experience
where you'll get to play as people
during the time of vikings
and follow them in their endeavors big
and small
while collecting exclusive rewards
whether you're an assassin's creed fan
with a heart for history
or a student looking to supplement your
knowledge the discovery tour viking age
will have you covered
assassin's creed valhalla doesn't stop
here
for the first time on an assassin's
creed title we'll be supporting the game
well into its second year well this year
will be a very active year for the game
we're already working on more expansions
for next year
something tells me that avor is not done
with odin yet
you